. Let's go next to Preston from Birmingham.
Now, is this Birmingham, Alabama, or United
Kingdom?
Preston from Birmingham.
Hi, can you hear me, David?
Yes, I can.
It sounds like it's Alabama, not not UK.
Yeah, you can tell no accent.
That was I was immediately able to deduce
that.
All right, David.
Well, I took the time to formalize my thoughts
for this question.
Oh, thank you.
I went ahead and wrote a thesis for you.
They'll submit for you to review.
Thank you.
So I have a few questions regarding Bernie
Sanders raised the Wage Act.
Sure.
So the Raise the Wage Act would add to twenty
five to the federal minimum wage every year
through twenty twenty five, right after that
the wage would be increased by the annual
percentage increase of the median hourly wage
for all employees.
Yes.
So my first question about this is, why are
they deciding to increase the wage by the
annual percentage increase of the median hourly
wage as opposed to something like adjusting
for inflation?
And also, why are they specifically excluding
annual percentage increases in salaries from
that calculation?
Well, I think that the there's a bunch of
different stuff there.
First of all, when we talk about the hourly
wage, you're talking about the wage for people
paid hourly.
So it is logical to me that you wouldn't index
it to salaried folks who might work 35 or
60 hours per week.
That part makes sense.
So maybe we can take that piece off the table.
I think you would look at if you're going
to index an hourly wage, you would look at
hourly workers.
Is that fair?
Yes.
OK, in terms of doing it to median rather
than inflation, I don't know the answer.
I've not I've not read about the reason.
The reason to do it median rather than mean
seems obvious.
And as people have given this example before,
if you put one hundred people in a room and
one of them is Bill Gates, the median wage
will be really high.
But the median may not be because so so median
rather than mean makes sense.
But as far as versus inflation, I've seen
a lot of proposals that would index the minimum
wage to inflation.
I don't know why it's being done to the median
hourly wage, but I would be interested in
learning why I would.
To completely agree with everything you're
saying, though.
Makes sense.
I've got one more question for you about this.
So Sanders is proposing that to twenty five
increase every year through twenty twenty
five.
What's your opinion on this time frame of
the roll out?
Do you think it would be faster to or it would
be better to increase this wage faster, maybe
as a way to benefit low wage earners and allow
them to put money back into the local economy
during the pandemic?
And on the other hand, I understand that small
businesses would be hurt by sudden wage increases,
as was addressed in the town hall last night.
Yeah.
So what's your opinion on this time frame?
Do you think this is a realistic goal?
Do you think it should go faster or slower?
So I would love for it to go faster, but I
recognize that it's extraordinarily unlikely
to be politically viable.
And when you look at senators like Kirsten
Sinema and Joe Manchin, who aren't even sure
they they want a 15 dollar minimum wage, the
idea of making it a 15 dollar federal minimum
wage tomorrow just seems so unlikely.
So I'm not surprised that they're looking
at phasing it in over time.
Now, of course, by twenty twenty five, a fifteen
dollar minimum wage is going to be a lot less
than it would be today because of inflation,
not a lot less.
I mean, the US has relatively low inflation,
but it's already going to be time to look
at the next step at that point in time.
But I'm not surprised because particularly
in places where the state minimum, a lot of
states already have minimum wages of 10, 11,
12, 14, even in places where they the the
state minimum wage really is still in the
sevens.
You're talking about more than doubling it
and whatever you believe the minimum wage
ultimately should be, and I believe it should
be much higher.
Doubling the minimum wage will have an economic
impact.
And so I'm not surprised at all that it would
be phased in over time.
And if Bernie is behind it, I think that he
started out well.
Yeah, I agree.
David, thank you for the time, taking time
to answer my questions.
So if you have a good day, you too.
All right.
Very good.
Great to hear from from our friends in Alabama,
as always.